la pollution n'a pas de frontières c'est
le jugement de la cour suprême dans une
décision rendue à 6 contre 3 le plus
haut tribunal du pays conclut que les
changements climatiques constituent un
défi existentiel et que l'inaction d'une
province aurait de graves conséquences
sur des intérêts extra provinciaux c'est
donc au nom de l'intérêt national que le
gouvernement fédéral a le droit
d'imposer une tarification sur le
carbone le ministre canadien de
l'environnement parle d'une journée
historique
le ton était moins victorieux en alberta
évidemment nous sommes déçus avec la
décision de la cour suprême
aujourd'hui le conservateur jason kenny
qui a été élu en faisant campagne contre
la tarification sur le carbone doit
décider s'il gardera la taxe d'ottawa ou
si elle imposera son propre système
comme l'a fait le québec on va consulter
les albertains et non les autres
provinces nos alliés pour déterminer le
meilleur face le meilleur politique la
saskatchewan elle entend maintenant
mettre en place son propre régime de
tarification
quant à d'oxford qui avait forcé les
stations-service ontarienne apposé des
autocollants contre la taxe fédérale
il a préféré envoyer son ministre de
l'environnement au front la bataille
judiciaire a beau être terminé
l'affrontement politique lui se poursuit
les conservateurs promettent d'abolir la
taxe fédérale même si la cour la juge
constitutionnel
je vais aussi avoir un plan sérieux et
claire sur l'environnement parce que on
doit réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il est très attendu ce
plan donc le chef est une auto la
bouilloire convaincre montrer son
sérieux il faudra des gestes concrets
pour faire oublier que son parti ne
reconnaît pas officiellement l'existence
des changements climatiques
ici laurence martin radio canada ottawa